are you actually a brown belt was that a
joke Brown bow yeah you're a brown bow
like how many stripes uh no Stripes no
Stripes stripeless okay is that part of
the process that you're working through
definitely probably process I mean I
think a black belt is just based upon
how much knowledge you have obviously
like you know if you're talking
competitive wise like from when I
started I was able to beat most black
belts that's just kind of how I was
gifted from my my wrestling experience
and uh you know the time will come when
it's right but I'm not in a rush at all
I'm I'm continuing I just kind of take
every day for what it is and try to
improve upon that I mean I want to give
him the black belt Nikki Ryan says he's
not ready
are you guys like us no gee folks do you
take that seriously like the black belt
or like how much does it come into play
into yeah I mean it's like Mickey Rod
said you know it's based off of
knowledge
um not just you know what you do at on
the competition match because you know
like he said he had years of wrestling
experience and obviously he's very
physically gifted so we grade based off
of the amount of knowledge that you have
like how do you measure knowledge
I think teaching is a good measurement
of it like how well you're able to show
the moves um and you know really make
sure that you have an understanding of
what you're doing that's an interesting
rank it's like
um it's something that takes many years
to accomplish and for a lot of people
it's truly meaningful it's like it
represents
particular step in a journey but for you
guys it's almost like different because
you've been so focused on competition
that I guess if you take it seriously it
is a big step for you too like it's
martial artists that that's bigger than
just being like top of the world
competitors right
so I thought it was a joke you guys are
actually taking it seriously like
studies of Rambo there's a brown belt
and he's and you're taking seriously the
rank of black belt and like it's part of
it's part of your journey think about
time I get a block about I'll be no more
pound per pound I think it'd be pretty
uh nice to accomplish that as a brown
belt and then maybe toss the black belt
on top maybe get promoted on on the
podium